when you have light skin you're not a
terrorist when it gets dark and people
like you always bring race into it it's
got nothing to do with race and
everything to do with people who kill
people yes people like you race B heard
you we had literally people saying the
Jews will not replace us and Donald
Trump said they're very fine people we
literally have people like I said going
against this Capital right here
committing a violent Insurrection but
for some strange reason when the number
one domestic Terror threat in America
and also increased Rec l in Europe and
the UK is white terrorists white
nationalist terrorists white ex
extremists I never hear anyone say you
know what we should ban them we should
Deport them oh what instead hear is they
have economic anxiety the double
standard here at play has to be exposed
right and I want people to really think
about what they're really advocating if
someone doesn't like your speech you
know what you're not just going to be uh
not tolerated you're going to be
deported especially if you're a person
of color how does that make a
multi-racial society that is both the UK
and America safer and better especially
and I'm speaking now as an American and
you know in the UK the rising domestic
Terror threat is not Islam extremism
which by the way exists it is white
nationalist extremism not a single word
about that but I hear all these Free
Speech Advocates all these people are
all about Western Civilization all all
of a sudden turned to censorship and all
of a sudden become authoritarian when it
comes to Muslims and people of hang on
why is that hang let me educate your
guest a little bit about his own
country pleas educate me pleas educate
me I I'm about to be quiet and I will
now first of all nobody's calling for
people to be deported because of their
views we have laws in this country
against organizations that are
prescribed as terrorists and I have no
problem with terrorists being removed
from this country under the laws of this
country secondly Donald Trump never said
that the people calling uh for the
eradication of Jews will find people if
you go and look at his quotes he
actually condemned them and they said
they should be condemned absolutely but
the people who were there protesting
about the statues they were the ones
that would find people and you had
people and I'm not talking about the
neo-nazis and the white nationalists
because they should be condemned totally
but you had many people in that group
other than neo-nazis and white
nationalists okay and the Press has
treated them absolutely unfairly now in
the other group also you you had some
fine people but you also had
troublemakers and you see them come with
the with the black outfits and with the
helmets and with the baseball bats you
got a you had a lot of bad you had a lot
of bad people in the other group
unfairly sir I'm sorry I just didn't
understand what you were saying you were
saying the Press has treated white
nationalists unfairly I just understand
saying there were people in that rally
and I looked the night before if you
look they were people protesting very
quietly the taking down of the Statue of
robertt el Lee I'm sure in that group
there was some bad ones the following
day it looked like they had some rough
bad people
neo-nazis uh White nationalists whatever
you want to call them but you had a lot
of people in that group that were there
to innocently protest and very legally
protest because you know I don't know if
you know they had a permit the other
group didn't have a perent so I only
tell you this there are two sides to a
story I I thought what took place was a
horrible moment for our country a
horrible moment now you should educate
yourself about those things and thirdly
you should educate about the fact that
regrettably I would quite like to have a
First Amendment here in the UK we do not
have a First Amendment and I would have
a lot more sympathy with your argument
if we hadn't spent the last 10 years
watching people be sacked from their
jobs for saying women are women and men
are men yeah and I would also add that
when you say that I'm not respecting
Free Speech V when I say I don't respect
people who won't condemn a mass they're
I didn't say you no no but they can say
it they can say it I just don't have to
respect it it's a bit like when I block
people on Twitter course you don't have
to respect it but when I when I block
people on on X for example formerly
Twitter and people say well you're
suppressing their free speech no I'm not
they can still tweet what the hell they
like I just don't have to read it I
don't have to hear it you know that this
that actually is what free speech is and
the First Amendment which is one of the
most powerful Protectors of free speech
in the world it doesn't cover many
things from M pornography to defamation
to all sorts of stuff is is not
protected by the First Amendment and
nobody I don't think who looks at this
sensibly would say that a terror group
that espouses not just hatred but
violent hatred and the mass killing of
people that is never protected by free
speech is it and should it be uh it it
shouldn't be but listen this is
interesting uh speaking about education
allow me to retort and educate and I'll
give you an example about the double
standard and I want you guys to really
respond to this speaking about terrorism
and violence on the platform you
mentioned X also known as Twitter one of
the wealthiest men Elon Musk has
repeatedly promoted the replacement
Theory an anti-semitic Terror uh anti
anti-semitic conspiracy that blames Jews
for trying to weaken and replace Western
Civilization with Muslims and immigrants
and lgbtq communities right that
conspiracy theory has radicalized
individuals to commit violence against
Jews against Muslims against black
people against Latinos that conspiracy
has been retweeted and platformed and
mainstreamed by the Republican party
people like Elise stefanic and Donald
Trump who by the way dined with Nick
Fuentes the leading white nationalist
leader in America you guys are fine with
that when it com to any other grp that
who said we're F wait a minute
said I WR a whole column it what are you
talking about good but you're not going
to deport them right are you going to
deport them are you going to are you
going to call them out for
for
said people who are citizens who are not
citizens of the country should be
deported if they're members of a
terrorist group why don't you understand
the distinction M of a terrorist group
and saying something us and UK should us
and UK government and National Security
go after these groups and these elected
officials and these organizations that
have literally repeated and mainstreamed
a conspiracy that has motiv ated
terrorists to commit
terrorism anyone who is a member of a
terrorist group should be prosecuted
under the law of the country in which
they are a terrorist group a terrorist
grou that's not what I asked well but
that's what I said so you were
challenging me about something I'm very
and I'm very
curious CU why you are not concerned
about this but in this in I didn't say I
wasn't concerned about it I said you
can't Deport citizens of the country in
which they live A and B I keep pointing
out out to you that the person we're
talking about in this case this NHS GP
he is a member of a terrorist group
we're not talking about him having the
wrong opinions people are allowed to
have the wrong opinions both in this
country and in your country is something
that we all celebrate as part of the
heritage of Western civilization and we
would all I hope defend the issue here
is we have laws in this country about
being a member of a terrorist group and
people who are members of a terrorist
group I hope you would agree with me
should be prosecuted to the full extent
of the law and if they are prosecuted to
the extent of the law and they are
foreign citizens should be deported will
we agree on
that we will agree then and I'll also
say this uh for those who are watching
especially the youth uh there's a great
meme a family guy meme where there's a
chart of who gets to be labeled a
terrorist and who doesn't uh the front
part of the chart is when you have light
skin you're not a terrorist when it gets
dark and darker people like you always
bring race into it it's got nothing to
do with race and everything to do with
people who kill
people yes people like you race baers
like heard yes and I have not heard you
really Express this much outrage against
the number one domestic Terror threat
against all our communities in America
and the UK which is rising white
National a dark skinned first generation
immigrant to the UK I don't play your
racial games stop using your skin color
as a way to shut other people up and
let's talk about the issue the issue
here is should we tolerate foreign
terrorist should we remove them and my
opinion is we should remove people who
are not conducive to this country and if
someone like me first generation
immigrant comes here and wants to be a
terrorist it is first generation
immigrants like me that at the front of
the queue to get them out okay it's been
a fascinating debate remove people are
not conducive to this been it's been
fascina about I actually think who are
terrorists yes I actually think V to be
fair to you I do think that the white
nationalism related terrorist acts that
we see increasingly is never played up
as much actually as islamist Terror was
particularly in the Heyday of al-Qaeda
and Isis I think it's a perfectly valid
point to make for what is worth I think
I've made that point actually before um
before I let you go uh Constantin you've
done a lot of filming with the pro
Palestinian marches in London what did
you
find well I actually went over the last
uh few months per we went to the protest
against anti-Semitism we went to two pro
Palestine protests we went to an
Extinction rebellious Rebellion protest
which was very very funny I encourage
people to go and watch that but at the
latest Pro Palestine protest in
particular there was some fascinating
scenes and you know we really tried to
talk to people with an open mind I don't
have actually contrary to the discussion
we've just had a particularly strong uh
position on it I'm interested really in
getting people's views and one of the
things that came through very strongly
is uh young people in particular of whom
there are many the way I would kind of
describe the demographics are it's a
mixture of sort of beards and head
scarves on the one hand and septum
piercings and colored hair on the other
um the young people who are there in
particular when you ask some very very
basic questions you know from which
river to let's take a look at a clip
actually we've got a we've got a clip
with some of this let's watch it here so
I just noticed the signs you got from
The River To The Sea Palestine will be
free what does that mean well it's quite
self expan how would that come about
what would happen to the Israelis
Etc I
don't I'm trying to think of how to word
it isn't it just as self- expans as the
area of land it's palestine's land
what's a socialist to father if I'm
being honest with you I just got this at
the stand over there okay uh I don't
actually know the definition of the word
it's father I mean it's kind of
laughable I don't think for a moment
that a lot of people on that Mark Mar
are that ignorant about it a lot of them
clearly are well informed and absolutely
marching because they want peace and
they want to cease fire and Gaza I
completely understand that but vajat
when you hear that there are a lot of
young people joining up in these marches
who are completely clueless and I
actually blame Tik Tock more than
anything which is the number one news
source now for kids under 25 and spews
just Relentless nonsense into their
heads and that's where they get their
news
uh this is where I'm going to stand up
for the Youth if you look at the youth
it's been a stunning change where most
youth people uh youth here and abroad
are actually if you will Pro Palestinian
and want the occupation to end and the
flip side to that pierce I would say is
the following for those who are watching
we're the same when it comes to Facebook
we're the same when it comes to X and
we're the same when it comes to
mainstream media you are a breath of
fresh air because you allow multiple
opinions to come on uh you know talk
about Palestinian side and Israeli side
in America you know that this wasn't the
case and so so for those people who are
terrified by the Tik Tok just think
about what limited viewpoints that you
got for 30 40 years and now for better
and for worse this young generation is
exposed to multiple narratives and they
see for themselves what's happening
which is why you see the shift in which
a lot of people especially in Israel and
here are horrified by the nyaho
government want an end to the occupation
want to cease fire hate Hamas hat hate
extremists in the N Yahoo government and
believe that Palestinians have a right
to Freedom yeah well certainly do in my
estimation but there is one clip uh
Constantine which really got to me it
was about me let's take a look so I I
see you've got a sign that there
journalism that get paid for selling
lies and I'm guessing that's Pierce
Morgan right why do you say that this is
journalism that's selling
lies um it's very obvious what is going
on all the lies about what happened on
the October 7th the justification for
the genocide they're all based on Lies
when you say lies about October 7th what
do you mean all those allegations that
we never saw any footages of of
decapitated children that Piers Morgan
always asked about and all those women
that get got uh gang raped I mean it was
quite extraordinary Constantine because
one of the problems with platforming
everybody actually for the last three
months is you end up with the extremes
on both sides hating you with equal
Vengeance and often being completely ill
informed actually about what I've
actually said um but it was enlightening
to see that because I see that all day
long on social media that kind of view
which is really based on a lack of
reality well there was a lot of that
going on in the protest and
interestingly I mean you say most people
there are well informed uh we released
in that half an hour documentary that
people can go to trigonometry our
YouTube channel and watch we released
every single interview that we did uh so
we haven't cherry-picked these moments
to make people look bad or anything like
that it contains they're shortened down
but they are basically the content of
what people said to us okay and I have
to say most of the people we spoke to a
didn't really seem that actually that
well informed most of them and secondly
I would say that was an awful lot of the
sort of thing you just heard where
people have some kind of way of
pretending October 7th didn't happen in
fact the first person you see in the
video talks about how it's a false flag
operation there seems to be a lot of
that going on too where where people are
sort of they they sort of wish away the
terrorist attack on October 7th and it
makes sense because if you're calling
for a ceasefire uh and you're calling on
Israel to unilaterally essentially
engage in ceasefire you have to pretend
October 7th didn't happen because
otherwise you'd be calling on Hamas to
hand over the hostages and the
terrorists who took them because that's
how you get a ceasefire yeah I mean one
of the biggest blowups I had vat was
after that interview with that doctor
actually uh in which I'd already read
out some quotes from another member of
this